people of the internet retro reckons who
are here and welcome back to harry
potter and the chamber of secrets
picking up where we left off last time
we are still here in
diagon alley ryan
ryan what am i talking about ron has
just informed us that we missed
the hogwarts express i don't know where
mrs weasley and jenny went
how they somehow got to the hogwarts
express in time when they were literally
just right beside us but somehow ron and
i
missed the train so now we're gonna talk
to ron and
hopefully make it to hogwarts let's see
what's going on here guys
ready to go to hogwarts harry yeah let's
do it
i'm really not sure about this we've got
to get to school haven't we
and even just leave straight from diagon
alley it's a real
emergency section 19 or something of the
restriction thingy you're sure you can
fly it okay
i mean look at this it's going fine i'm
doing all right aren't i yeah
exactly i suppose
so far look harry
oh no oh no thanks have turned dark
yikes oh
oh my goodness oh my goodness ron
what the whopping willow laughs
the whole thing willow just left oh
that's great
that's great
don't worry i'll come and get you the
whooping willow scotland do anything
else
hurry up harry
oh that is great dude let's see what the
remembrall says a rescue
rod
uh remember all what am i supposed to be
doing at this moment
oh that's right rescuing my best friend
what do you say let's make it happen all
right
what oh my goodness dude
don't take away so many beans man
oh i need i thought you had to like cast
a spell i think i'm just supposed to
wait
now go there we go good job harry
gotta save those birdy bop beans man
fred and george need their beans
all right so we're down on the ground
now
any birdie by beans over here yeah there
we go
all right try and make up for what we
just lost right there
what no
getting beaten by these vines
okay more beans imagine
imagine if your best friend like needs
rescuing and you're like hold on
i'm trying to gather these speeds here i
just need a few more beans
okay well i mean this mushroom's got
quite a few so
we're trying to max them out guys all
right can we hop over this
yes oh goodness
no not losing any more beans to you guys
oh i shouldn't i knew i shouldn't have
went in for that last one
i was trying to save it but
all right
okay forget the beans forget the beans
am i going the right way though let's
see
yeah i think so okay camera please turn
back
what i just walked into it puffapods can
be hit with lupindo or picked up and
thrown
be careful however as their spores can
cause dizziness
all right
[Music]
what how am i supposed to get by this
one
we're just gonna try to go for it
i'm just gonna go for it
all right i think we made it
no no
[Music]
you might be able to max out our birdie
about beans in this area actually
then we won't have to keep spamming this
everywhere we go just to try and find
beans
oh two
[Music]
all right that's 40. almost there i'm
gonna pick this one up
how far can he carry it oh
he does walk slower just chuck it off
the side
all right
okay where is ron guys
oh no oh no
oh goodness i didn't see all of them
[Music]
oh there's two spots that we can go to
right here
so look at this we can go under
oh they come back yeah i definitely
think this is like
this right here is probably a secret
maybe not
we probably just missed a wizard guard
in the other spot
can i go back please can i go back
there are many objects in the world
which when hit with flupindo will
release items that you may need on your
adventure
these could be anything from birdy bot
beans to health boosting cauldron cakes
yeah we kind of figure that one out oh
it's not gonna let me go back
hey get away you savage
well hopefully it wasn't anything too
important that we missed
oh we gotta destroy so many of those
things
hey get back
[Music]
no
there we go all right
that should be it
the question oh 48 we're almost there oh
look at him up there dude
full blast flopindo
oh come on one more there we go all
right maxed out
on birdie bot beans what i want to open
that chest please
please please can i oh we need to go to
this side
wizard card oh cauldron cake we don't
need it though
we actually didn't even need it
i will use the save point
okay now though thanks to this tree wait
i think we're supposed to go
okay if we go that way
dude this is actually a really big area
i want to go that way first
because i want to see what's in that
chest
oh we can call hedwig down right there
[Music]
all right so let's go get the chest
first
using our wall sneak ability here
by the way guys if we're meeting for the
first time i'm just a dad who loves
games and the stories
they tell we post videos every week here
on youtube
and i appreciate you checking out this
video if you're here for the first time
uh definitely consider subscribing if
you enjoy the video
really appreciate that wizard card let's
go
all right who do we have who do we have
number six
glad more peaks glanmore peaks 1677-1761
slayer of the sea serpent of kromer
very cool very cool
all right we got a wall sneak back
and hopefully we're close enough to can
i
cast the spell no we can't so we're
gonna have to like
yeah we're probably getting hit by him
right here to be honest with you
we're just falling down it's okay though
that's okay nothing bad happened nothing
bad happened all right let's go on back
and see what head wakes up to
hedwig i call upon your power
come to me in my time of aid
all right students are warned that the
area surrounding the whopping willow and
the forbidden forest on which it borders
are out of bounds
this is due not in the least to the
number of wild
guy trashes gee trashes
that roam the forest if students should
find themselves being approached by
these giant dog spirits they are advised
that they can be warded off with a lumo
spell
all right cool so hedwig just like
brought me information this time
no ladder or anything to get out all
right all right fair enough hedwig fair
enough
what happens when you try to be able to
count i'm at the max right now
all right before i do that though we
need to go check out this side
see if there's anything over here that
we should be exploring
i feel like there's a secret over here
don't tell me it's just like mushrooms
for more beans
there's gotta be a chest dude they blend
in so well
in this game so many of the areas so far
have been like
they're just sitting right in the middle
of a brown area number four
grogan style yo grogan stomp possible
hogwarts legacy gentleman right here
1770 to 1884
popular minister of four magic appointed
in 1811 grogan stump
there's actually a lot to grogan stuff
if you're interested in the harry potter
hogwarts legacy video game it takes
place in the late 1800s that's all we
know about it so far
but yeah read up on grogan stump i'm
probably going to do a video on him at
some point actually because
there's a lot of interesting stuff about
him
and i think he very likely will be in
hogwarts legacy
at least mention i don't know if he's
going to be like a featured character or
anything
but i do think he will be mentioned is
that another chess down there
i kind of want to take a chance okay
i went the wrong way all right
it's all right we just need to get back
up right here and then i can hop down
oh come on harry come on harry
there you go there you go yeah i want to
go to this side
oh there is a little secret area right
here
i thought it might be a chest but wait
what
why can't i go in there
what is going on there guys that is
definitely meant to be a place
that is definitely meant to be a place
you can crawl why can't i not crawl in
there
maybe that's how you get out later or
something maybe i'm not supposed to go
there yet
yeah i mean otherwise what is the point
of that right there
okay so now let's go all right i think
we've explored
everything over here so we just need to
go back over there where we
oh called hedwig
and then go down this way said something
about these dog creatures
good guy trashes or something
oh yeah whoa look at these things dude
stay back why is luma
i was about to say why is lumos not
running out and then
it did
[Music]
are these things actually from the book
i do not remember these creatures at all
[Music]
i'm gonna have to look this up now after
i finish filming this
all right there we go i think we got
them all i mean i'm sure i think she
she had to approve everything i believe
in terms of
the creatures and spells and all that
that went into the games
[Music]
all right now we're back maxed out on
beans again all right let's crawl into
here
and let's see let's see if it comes out
in that spot that i was just trying to
get to earlier
i could see that but then oh nope nope
oh goodness they're chasing me
a lot more this time a lot more
[Music]
hey back you savage
dude there's a way more because look how
long it's taking that
health bar to go down oh this is not
good guys
at least we have that vial remember we
still have the wigan well potion
there we go just snipe them all from
above
where are you at dude what they had the
same idea
are you serious right now man
oh no this is not going well guys we're
down to 30 beans
our health is at half let me up there
oh is that a wiggin well potion i think
it is actually
it's almost like the game knows that you
might die at this part
there you go harry shoot him
blast him we got time for this wizard
card trust me
plenty of time to check out the wizard
guard i need one more to up my overall
health bar
hespe starkey hey another late 1800s
we've got a witch here hesper starkey
which who studied the use of phases
of the moon in potion making
hesper starkey so that is two wizard
cards we've gotten today
featuring what no
oh that was not good all right let's
just take all these guys out
and then maybe we can actually explore
this area a little bit
because right now i'm just i'm trying to
explore and not die
can i crawl in here yet oh you can
actually
let's go and jump over here again first
and let's
blast this dude no
look at him taunting me did you see that
he's motioning like come at me bro
and i just took damage for that right
there oh my goodness guys
okay that's actually good though
what do you think we gotta take out like
three or four more
where's he yet
i'm just gonna wait right here this
seems to be the best spot
one more one more should do it oh just
saw him
nope over here where'd he go
there he is okay hopefully that stops
them from
respawning looks like it does
okay good all right so i've got a couple
of different
ways that we can go at this point i want
to try and see what's over there
but i don't want to trigger another cut
scene like if i go
darn it what kept you harry
i can't hang around here all night you
know very funny ron
now how on earth am i going to release
you good question
is there some kind of weak spot on the
tree you can cast a spell at
i wonder i wonder
see what i did there all right all right
all right ron hold on buddy
oh jeez dude this thing is not playing
around
wait it's not the eye we're not supposed
to target the eye
there we go oh now now we need to target
the eye
oh yeah that was major damage just one
hit
head wig hedwig bringing me the pumpkin
pasty
[Music]
dude i can't believe how many birdie bop
beans we have lost
we're about to be back down to zero okay
18. okay we got to wait for that little
glint
in there the hand did you guys see
earlier how the hand kind of shined
when it was like that right there blast
it blast it
now get a shot on the eye all right so
one more hit
one more hit and we cannot afford to
take any hits although we do have the
wig and weld potion still
in the vial so i think that would that
would cover us but
i believe all we have to do is kind of
hang back like this
and then when they
judy is using the car now
[Music]
okay now this one's going to attack oh
he's throwing boulders
jeez i do not remember this do not
remember him throwing boulders at me
yeah they're they're doing a lot more
attacks this time
come on what is with all the creatures
taunting you in this game man
taunting you after they attack blasted
blast and blast them
now get the eye there we go
come on ron let's get out of here very
much appreciated sorry it took me so
long
sorry it took so long you better get to
move on we don't want professor snape
catching us out so
late why don't you try that door harry
the only thing i'm not looking forward
to this time is seeing
snape let's just hope he's left because
he missed out on the defense against the
dark arts job again
well he might have been sacked i mean
everyone hates him
or maybe he's waiting to hear why you
two didn't arrive
dang sports express professor's name
we uh we were my search of the grounds i
noticed that considerable
damage seems to have been done to a very
valuable whomping
willow very valuable speaking with
professor mcgonagall
later that treated more damage to us
than we
silence i would advise you both
to make yourself dang it don't even get
to enjoy the feast
but professor tonight we go
and count yourselves lucky if i should
catch either of you out after tonight
i will definitely deduct house points
to duct house points come on harry i
want you outside the entrance hall
alright let's go
yes look at this you guys we have
finally made it to hogwarts
in harry potter and the chamber of
secrets and oh look at this we've got
the bloody baron
right away greeting us who do we have
over here
one of the prefects hello how are you
get to the common room oh
yes yes right away right away
and guys i think this is going to be an
excellent place for us to end
today's episode if you all enjoyed this
video make sure you give it a thumbs up
come back next week when we actually
start doing activities inside hogwarts
as always thank you all so much for
watching
i'll talk to you again soon